Hôm qua 2 thằng chiến năm 2018, sư bảo Rồi Gä Sa quế qua Philippines với sức sỏe
hơn 2.6 km, chờ thành cơn bảo mạnh nhất thế giới từ đầu năm 2018.
Bảo vệ mươi lớn, lợi đất và lũ quá tả nhiều tình phía bắc khiến hàng chục nghiệp với phải sơ tán.
Rồi Gä Sa dự kiến tiếp tục xí dấu dần khi tiến sách hồng công, Trung Quốc và minh năng Trung Quốc trong
hôm nay, sông vẫn duy trí sức sỏe từ đường bảo cấp bà với khả năng gây thiệt thạy lớn.
Hôm công đã bán hình kình bảo bảo cấp tám, yêu cầu về lớn dân nghiệp và dụ vật tải dương hỏa đậu.
Hôm nay trong chuyến bay bị vị trong đó có khu hắng khách thạy pacific và hôm công ở lại,
có vực biển lối hôm công, Trung Quốc, Mức cao và dụ hai cũng tạm nắm.
Nguyên dân độ sốt thích chữ lượng thực, yêu cầu hàng xí thiệt chồng chân.
Đai khi tự hôm công, Trung Quốc, tình bảo rời gà sạm mang theo sợ dịch trên 2.7 km,
với hình y cơ sống lớn cao tới bún đến năm mát có kỳ tức tự thạy của xíu bảo hát tôi năm 2018.
Nhà chức chức đã phát khách và trình bị diễn chẳng chú hình cấp cho kư dân vùng chú.
Tại tình còn đông, các tình phố lớn như thông quyến và còn chư đã đông khu hợp.
Nguyên hạt động sản xuất, đông thời trình bị sử tán khoảng 40,000 người ở bún bên liền.
Giờ chức kính bảo các đợt sống cao tới bệ mế sế sức hiện tại khu vực dương hạnh.
Châu Phi đó, bất cao cũng bục tất cả sông bạch đông khu vực dự này.
Như để phương khác ở mình đang chung khúc chỉ khai địa pháp uống phó, tôi chật tìm kế sành đến dự hơn tạm trong điểm chủ ẩn cân cấp.